foreign
[Music]
also previously on well Willow I guess
look we send multiple movies in the same
franchise possessing the exact same name
on our sort of famous uncle's channel so
why would you think we'd be any
different here we thought the war was
over and soon after returning home
Willow had a vision yes because if you
need to show a future incident in a
fantasy story that will need to be dealt
with eventually to save the world
there's nothing more original than one
of the main characters having a vision
about it and if you're concerned there
isn't a prophecy to be dealt with as
well Willow has your ass covered ah it
was the only way I could protect her the
only way you could protect your child
was to lie to her about who she really
is sounds like an excuse for she
parenting to me this isn't Santa Claus
you're lying to a child about their past
and identity you're ensuring a nice
Payday for a future therapist who will
have to untangle all this [ __ ] our Mass
would take away basically 100 of your
peripheral vision a great idea in a
sword fight because I don't think they
are since they're just friends who are
sparring could they not choose the
location that's a little less
frightening they're fighting on a cliff
one could easily fall off of and would
most likely die and we already mentioned
their peripheral vision is seriously
impaired you know the skill
and there's Talent
and I just happen to have both of them
with a generous amount of arrogance just
because you get called out on your
vanity doesn't make vanity any less of a
sin and vanity is definitely my favorite
sin I'm not sure Willow is a kid's show
but it's enough of a family show I find
it oddly introduced to Prince Eric by
showing us his o face I love you
confessing your love to a guy that just
confirmed that some of the stories about
it might be true we'll hit a little bit
see which ones he's talking about first
they might be the really bad ones King
hosta with a great host was seen riding
into the veil well I'm sure Robert Aaron
has enough forces in the Erie to protect
the veil and if not I'm sure his cousin
Sansa will back him up wait which
fantasy show am I sitting again and what
do we suppose she means by presentable
well I suppose there's not covered in
dirt and grass oh whoa she's so
particular rich kids
that's stealing we send Aladdin when he
did it you bet your ass will send you
too if you need food ask the shopkeeper
for help if they say no and are rude
about it then you can steal from them
that's just science
dude if you didn't want people to see
you kissing her maybe don't do it right
in the street in front of everyone I saw
everything being this excited about
seeing your brothers everything why do
you look like you've been rolling around
in Grass he really doesn't there's not a
bit of grass on his clothes and his hair
looks like he just showered and
blow-dried it so unless the script told
you he's been rolling around in the
grass you wouldn't have any evidence to
suggest such a conclusion what's that in
your neck oh I got bit by a fire moth I
think fish was straight sure wasn't a
dove siblings Lachlan told me he found
you and Jay to top the canyon maze again
you know I don't like you playing on
those rocks yeah we already covered this
Source you're really gonna need you to
keep up you're picking out my clothes
now we're really doing the cliche mom
daughter character conflict again it was
tired and brave it's Beyond tired now
please find a new way to drive
development between fantasy characters
pretty lackluster reaction to whispered
ominous voices sorcia what are you a
Skyrim NPC nonsense nothing gets through
the barrier ever oh well in that case
feel free to be even more dismissive of
the Queen's concerns we all grow from
stories of your parents yep and that's
what Disney's banking on for your
interest in this series the stories you
grew up on courtesy of Ron Howard and
quick while you're distracted by
Nostalgia they're increasing the price
of Disney plus hope you don't mind the
one with the lifts in the face that
describes every human being in this room
maybe you could try specifying hair
color or clothes and for 200 moves we've
maintained a civil Alliance how long is
a moon exactly why are you such a
confusing measurement for the passage of
time why not just use months they even
have some of the same letters and
tomorrow Prince Graydon marries my
daughter kit are we really doing another
princess doesn't want to marry the
prince storyline there are other options
for plot and character arcs I don't
remember a story about aeon being forced
to marry faramir against will to unite
Gondor and Rohan probably because she
was too busy killing the witch king of
angmar my point is stop it getting
acquainted with my betroth here but
you can go wherever you want
because you've made abundantly kit is
introduced as a strong Fierce
independent woman and immediately turns
spoiled and whiny as soon as something
doesn't go her way it's not as if she's
just now finding out about this
Arrangement she's had a lot of time
before now to work out her angst the
scene just feels forced for the sake of
dramatic tension have you ever heard the
story of tiramis
she was a princess cashmere continuing
to tell your story even though the
person did not answer your initial
question or tell you whether or not they
even wanted to hear the story
but I want to miss
you can absolutely be upset about being
forced into this marriage but putting a
gourd on your brother's head picking up
a knife and risking his life to prove a
point seems like a dick move we are
supposed to like this character right
he's gonna talk to the king smooth
everything over explain people should
stick to chasing girls rather than
sticking your nose in masses that you're
incapable of understanding and are not
your concern [ __ ] all the way off queen
of on your children Eric just ran a play
in masterful diplomacy to salvage a mess
and you're gonna scold him for getting
involved with how often she snaps at her
kids it's no wonder kit turned out so
unlikable and Cat distracts himself with
anything that's nice to him kid I'm not
going anywhere maybe you should your
mother and sister are truly awful people
but what if it was what if it was better
thing I keep asking myself about this
show somehow makes it into the episode
but hopefully not a green night because
your life will just be super confusing
and weirdly metaphorical and then at the
end of it you'll probably lose your head
you know there's nothing Brave about
running away kind of ironic how just a
few minutes ago we saw a kid accusing
Eric of leaving just like their father
and now here she is doing that very
thing I'm really curious about what the
purpose of the cage helmet is because
there's a lot of Open Spaces where the
face and head could easily be reached by
a weapon or even a fist why is this
design hey Leo how do you think we
should handle the first big action
sequence in this series well John I was
thinking we could get a dozen fog
machines let them rip and make it nearly
impossible to see anything that's
actually happening man Leo this is
exactly why you get paid the big bucks
Leo sorry to bother you again but what
are you thinking in regards to showing
this evil magic guy's Powers well since
everything is foggy and super dark I was
thinking maybe some super dark particle
effects I mean damn Leo you just know
how to bring a tear to someone's eye I'm
so proud of you
quit spinning your sword like that it's
the third time you've done it in the
last 30 seconds and you're gonna hurt
someone on your team leave the rule of
cool for Dungeons and Dragons here's
what they came for good thing you were
looking out your window to witness
something this series didn't bother show
showing the rest of us you're the
commander of the packlicate oh the pack
arcade I definitely know what that is
and understand its importance in this
context I've known Eric since the day he
was born and he's as close to a son as
I'll ever have
at least that I'm aware of did this
seemed like a good time for a quirky
quip because I don't think anyone has
time for this her son's been kidnapped
by monsters man yeah no I think we're
good fellowship-wise thinking that name
dropping a superior work of fantasy
makes your lackluster series any better
the last thing that Eric said to me was
that he would never leave me and when he
said it I
I didn't care then why should we Skip
and I just Define not by skill in battle
but by the olds they keep I mean skills
matter a little it's not like a knight
can be about to lose a fight flashback
to an oath they made and then find
renewed power to overcome their foe this
is an anime bro stop spinning your
weapons For the Love of All that is good
even this highly trained and experienced
Knight flinched writing cantering
Galloping trotting still more horses
horsing excitement have you ever been in
a fight you mean like verbally you know
she didn't mean like verbally Dove this
script makes most of the main characters
smart and capable until it doesn't need
them to be anymore and I hate it
seriously you brought a flute he brought
a flute wow
wow he bever's performance is maybe the
best part of this episode and I
graciously tip my sin cat to you Milady
I know this is a silly question
but what is the barrier actually that's
actually not a stupid question it's a
pretty damn important question for the
audience to know the answer to what is
stupid is the show taking 36 minutes to
get us a solid definition
[Music]
I'm not sure why this episode felt we
needed a guy giving a creepy nod and
smile after finding out two women or a
couple cliche but here we are the
kitchen mate is that her official name
why does nobody call her by her it's
because she's actually a Laura Danon
isn't it look at this you'd better come
take a look at this cliche you stand at
the threshold good thing Flash Thompson
came along because otherwise no one
would have been able to read this scroll
and they would all be it's neat how that
worked out so well for everyone
healer of worlds
stirs from his deathless Slumber imagine
being this idiot at the campfire recap
having to explain I don't know what
happened I saw some ancient writing and
blood on the wall in the most important
gate of all times and when I read the
first part the ground shook so I just
kept reading if you're not Vigilant at
each moment
I swear you will not survive the
negative here is that their leader has
been killed the positive thing though is
that now Dove has her own horse not that
she'll use it
but why we just went over the fact that
Dove has her own horse now why are you
making things more difficult than they
need to be kid we're supposed to like
kit right forget the fact that none of
the horses tried to stop forget the fact
that a fall from this high into the
water probably would have resulted in
horse legs broken in several pieces the
bone whatever still have arrows and Bows
don't they why aren't they shooting at
them so you hoped an ancient word in a
language the horses hadn't been trained
in would convince them to stop except
they didn't stop they overrode their
will to survive and launched off a cliff
into water this Show's dumb did you
steal this blade from cloud because it
looks like you stole this blade from
cloud I just think you should be in love
with someone before you commit to
spending the rest of your life with them
right did you try telling Disney that
we're looking for the sorcerer Willow
congratulations you found it meaning the
dude pretending to be the dude behind
the dude that is not the dude but is a
dude trying to protect the main dude a
prisoner of the width of Crone who
dwells in the immemorial city but lies
beyond the shattered sea good thing
we've got Willow here who's well versed
in the sorcery of exposition
[Music]
casting a touch spell without making a
saving throw for consent
[Music]
so Dove is a Laura which is a cool
enough twist but they hit the woman who
was going to save the entire Kingdom one
day away by making her a [ __ ] servant
what the [ __ ] sorsha you are a Laura
Dannon lost blood of chimeria future
Empress High Priestess sent from sources
of the nine Realms the unburned The
Breaker of Chains the Mother of Dragons
or seriously what show am I even
watching
the spell didn't work
so
we're getting married
that's weird right No Sleep Till Boston
the halfling was dear to the IC know
that he suffered greatly at the hands of
his host what do you think we're gonna
die
I wish someone told me I'm really scared
of dying and the Dutch my mother once
told me about a band of mercenaries that
came to a peaceful Planet so finally the
people resisted when they returned
demanding their tribute the people
shouted back in one voice no more so
they cut off the tongue of every last
man woman and child
that is a tree
[Music]